it's been an amazing 2017 for League of
Legends with some great plays and even
greater stories so in honor of some of
the best player storylines of the year
we put together at the top 10 but before
we get into that be sure to check out
the score esports builds calm to help
take your league skills to the next
level and now for our list of the top 10
best player storylines of the year
kicking off our list is the rookie
superstar Mike Young who helped North
America win the rift rivals showdown
against you and placed 10th with Phoenix
won in the summer split might young
exploded onto the NAC in this summer
with impressive performances on carry
junglers that quickly earned him a fan
followings and despite that
disappointing 10th place finish mike
young earned Rookie of the split for his
stellar play and ended a year off by
signing or GSM for 28 but as far as I
can remember TSM has been the team that
I have thought of wanting to join
because of its professionalism so he is
still relatively inexperienced Mike
Young will definitely be a player to
watch heading into Mexico tomorrow gonna
have to be the real hero it's been good
has he been amazing he might be able to
kill execute Mike look at the steel the
way the Bourbon is getting chunk he has
to be careful with you to buy time
because he who comes in at ninth on our
list
helped Royal never give up win the
spring split in the LPL come second in
the summer and place in the top four at
the World Championships he is also
China's all-star ad carry one of the
LPL's most veteran players Guzzi was a
key figure in China's move toward all
Chinese rosters in 2017 and RNG were one
of its most successful examples
[Applause]
brother roommate gets out of the way in
our chief a five Suzy is a part of
China's league of legends history and
thanks to his play this year he is also
a part of its future with more Chinese
teams looking to follow the examples of
squads like royal and oMG we're excited
to see where the region's domestic
talent can go
-
a pencil but it feels like one that
crowd knows how big that was the
inhibitor already exposed officia with
his hands up easy in eighth is ignore
who play sports with misfits in the
spring split and second in the summer
he is also Europe's all-star support as
a relatively new team misfits put up
strong results in 2017 but besides
making it to the summer final against g2
their story got really interesting at
the World Championship thanks in large
parts at ignores innovative support play
on Leona and Blitzcrank the plucky
misfits took SPT to five peaks and came
within inches of knocking the defending
champion out of the tournament
keep creating pics to get to parents it
was further than anyone expected misfits
to go and though SKT t1 in the end it
was one of the most exciting series of
the year I think we all know we could
have taken it today
maybe we all know we should have taken
it today but with that said this is by
far and away the best showing a European
team has ever had coming in at number 7
ik smithy plays fifth sixth in the
spring split with CLG second with
immortals in the summer split and
attended the world championship X myth
these story in 2017 really comes down to
the summer split yeah gods he came into
an immortals roster that struggled to
find its footing in a spring split
placing seven and he changed everything
after seal G and immortal swap junglers
start off and expand all eyes were on a
flashy seemingly empowered CLG roster
but ik smith he smashed those
expectations and all that they can do
now is get one consolation prize but it
smithy block so he flipped the script on
an immortal squad the community had
largely written all his stabilizing
presence in the jungle was a huge factor
in immortals making it to the summer
finals in North America and although the
team did not find much success at Worlds
it probably wouldn't have made it there
at all without expenditures at Silverman
shuttle stop back befo about that maker
TV with the rest of the team apart
that's gonna be game number six on our
list is Europe's veteran ad carry
reckless fanatics roster of relatively
untested players put up surprisingly
consistent results in the EU LCS this
year placing third in both splits and
thanks to his performance this summer
reckless was named the MVP but it was at
Worlds that reckless led the team to its
most surprising result
to the quarterfinals after an oath
restarts to the Liberty fnatic made it
further than anyone could have expected
and that is not gonna be enough to get
the killer back does go down records
against food-giver the fight fun to
point out that takes him down but after
being handed a rough defeat my role
never give up in the quarterfinals
wreckless was devastated he'd taken his
team further than anyone expected but it
wasn't enough to make a deeper run at
Worlds that said reckless has resigned
with fnatic for three more years and
we're excited to see what he can do in
2018 a massive respect to him what he's
done throughout his career we hope to
see him continue number five on our list
is doublelift double lifts 2017 started
with a low as the veteran ad carry took
a step back from the scene after a
grueling end to 2016 but his passion for
the competitive scene drove him back to
the rift sooner than expected
doublelift subbed in for Team Liquid to
help the team salvage a tough spring
school job will kill for SS he returned
to TSM for the summer and helped the
team win another domestic title though
they went on to struggle at Worlds but
the ending to his year might be the most
significant with doublelift
returning to Team Liquid in earnest
ahead of the 2018 spring split we're
excited to see what seems like a
friendly rivalry blue probably making
guys pretty sad because I really want to
crush just on this year number four on
our list is crown who placed third in
the spring split and fourth in the
summer but crowns biggest achievement of
the year his win at the 2017 World
Championship came after a year of
personal struggles for the mid laner
Buddha Kobe
money
crown might not have been the strongest
midlaner
in Korea this year but along with his
teammates on Samsung he overcame
personal adversity and brought it all
together when it mattered most first
part for crown Browns story is proof the
persistence and hard work can take you
all the way number three on our list
BDD became the starting mid laner on a
lingerie officer that had a terrible
spring split but with the help of their
summer roster Long's you brought it back
to win the split and though that had a
lot to do with prey and gorillas
leadership BDD was a huge factor in
their summer run going toe-to-toe with
the likes of faker and finally living up
to his enormous potential grandeur to
dwell Vidia spring alpaca song
[Music]
coming in at number two is ambition who
was also part of Samsung's third place
spring split and fourth place summer
rosters but out world ambition led his
team to the summoner's comes with a huge
300 win over SKT in the finals sit down
and psych rim they get the first kill
but for ambitions the win was a story
for years Baker just executes ambition
in that mid lane after what seems like a
lifetime in eSports ambition finally got
his revenge on faker and what better way
to do it than our league's biggest stage
Oh Jim got a ton of money come carry on
don't stop cuttin contain commentary at
all Kuniko
and finally at number one who else could
it be but faker fakers 2017 started off
strong was another domestic title and a
win at the midseason Invitational but in
the back half of the year the world's
most successful player and most
successful team stumbled when people
called the best Chinese deep
Insp the Freudian world champions the
final every one of the fakers phenomenal
play in 2017 cemented him as the best
player in the world
absolutely devastates the ranks the kt
rolster a triple killer him but it was
his defeat at the end of the year that
showed us a new side of faker not
satisfied with his many accolades faker
was devastated by his loss he'll enter
2018 hungry with something to prove once
again and we're excited to see where he
goes it's time to make building your
champions easier introducing the score
eSports as new builds calculator which
allows you to plug in items and runes to
figure out which build gives you the
best stats the new builds page also
gathers information on what the top
players and your favorite pros are
building so you'll be able to try them
out yourself take control of your
champion and try out the new feature on
the score a sports is builds website by
clicking on the link in the description
below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button